How highly do you recommend the whole house EMF product you sell?
Well, there's different whole house EMF products that we sell.
There's one that you connect electrically,
you have to get an electrician to connect it to your box
that will help block dirty electricity in your house.
That one, it's the ones serve different purposes.
So that one I think is a better product.
He drugs sells a whole house disc.
Of course, it depends on bigger houses, obviously.
To help block, let's take that back.
He drugs disc don't block EMFs.
They mitigate EMFs.
So they help change it to a calmer form.
So it's not dangerous to your body.
That's the heat run is the same company that makes the small little ones
that you stick on your phone.
Are those great?
I think they're great.
Yes.
So they're great units.
How beneficial are they?
That's another question.
It's an impossible.
If you want to be objective about everything,
it's very hard to objectify that.
The unit that connects to the house to clean dirty electricity,
that's easy to objectify because there's data on how that works.
We have one connected to our house.
I think they're extremely beneficial.
They actually pay for themselves in electricity
that you'll actually save throughout the year two.
So I think those are more beneficial
than the heat run discs.
And partly it's that if you get the heat run discs,
it's like nobody has ever said to me,
oh my gosh, I feel so much better having that thing.
But I have had people say they feel better
with either the plug-in units or the whole house unit
that blocks dirty electricity.
So I would say the whole house unit
that blocks dirty electricity are better.